[Music]
we've now covered survivability in solo
builds and the versatility of skill
power builds in this video we'll discuss
DPS builds these are not so dissimilar
to the solo builder showed in part two
except much like the skill power built
you don't have anywhere near the
survivability but unlike the skill power
built you can't just sit right back with
the DPS build you really need to play
the cover based game out of the three
basic build types solo skill power and
DPS I would call this the most difficult
place tile to learn and play effectively
however once you master your movement
and learn to position yourself and
utilize cover properly the sort of build
will provide considerably more damage
than either of the other two builds
heavy NPCs and named bosses will drop
incredibly quickly and this includes a
legendary missions and incursions
because of the difficulty of this build
I wouldn't consider this a good build to
be running solo hard and challenging
missions would be fine
but I wouldn't recommend using this
build to try solo legendary missions or
the resistance DPS builds best utilized
when playing with other build types and
a team or as a minimum with a support
built like a healer I found this very
effective with a tank and healer with
the tank soaking up the damage in the
heal if keeping you alive and boosting
your skills the DPS build is free to mow
down everything that gets in your way
with any build video I post up you
should be using these as a guide only
the intention is for you to use them as
a starting point and then adapt them to
your style of play I'll do my best to
show a few different options within the
builds but you'll need to try these out
and make the choice for yourself as per
usual I'll be keeping this as short and
concise as possible at the end I'll have
a couple of cheat sheets that will sum
up the builds covered in this video
please let me know in the comments if I
can provide a little more detail on
anything
the set will focus this video around
will be strikers this set focuses on
maximum damage output as you can see
from the four piece bonus you can get up
to a hundred percent increased damage
but you need to be able to land your
shots missing shots will heavily reduce
the bonus the four piece strikers set is
generally suited more for PC where there
is a lot more control over the crosshair
but even on console this is still a set
capable of unleashing huge amounts of
damage plus it'll be good practice for
when you manage to get a hold of the six
piece classified strikers which is
currently one of if not the most
powerful set in the game right now both
in PvE and PvP console or PC it should
be noted that this build has been based
around consoles and for those of us that
may have less than perfect aim there are
a few stability rolls in here that PC
users should be able to skip this build
consists of four piece strikers a
tenacious mask and savage gloves the
tenacious mask gives you a 10% damage
increase for ten seconds after using a
mid kit the tenacious mask could be
swapped out for a refreshed mask that
will give a little more of a health
boost from your healing skills and mid
kit you'll have seen that I've used the
savage gloves and a few other builds too
these are probably the best high-end
gloves available right now the 7%
increase in in critical hit chance is
pretty decent and most of the time
you'll be shooting at targets out of
cover four pieces have been rolled into
firearms with one and two stamina
although this build is not capable of
just face tanking everything that comes
at you you don't want to place every
piece of gear into firearms being a
glass cannon with this build will have
you spending more time on the ground
than firing your weapon and if my
calculations are correct if you're not
shooting your gun this will have
considerable impact on your damage over
time you want to have a little bit of
toughness I'd say a minimum of 400,000
this will allow you to take a few hits
and have a little bit of time to
readjust your position health has been
rolled onto the chest and knee pads
enemy armor damage onto the mask and
gloves damage to elites
onto the mask and knee pads as per usual
arrow capacity has been rolled onto the
chest and backpack and extra stability
onto the backpack the holster has been
rolled unto critical hit charts this is
only a 4% increase so instead you could
use skill haste to have your skills come
back a little bit faster
the gloves our main piece of gear for
increasing weapon damage has assault
rifle damage and critical hit damage if
you're feeling a little too squishy
change some of these attributes to
health on kill or if you've managed to
get a ninja buck messenger bag there's a
few other options this build consists of
three piece strikers two piece Nomad and
the ninja bike messenger bag with the
ninja bike you'll be gaining the two and
three piece Nomad bonus 15% health on
kill and a constant heal even during
combat the three piece Nomad bonus isn't
that amazing so alternatively you could
run one piece nomads and one piece
technicians instead giving you the 15%
health on kill and 15% skill haste
allowing you to get your skills back
even faster both of these options will
give you increased survivability
all right on to the business into the
build here I am using one of my
favorites a high rate of fire assault
rifle the light waiting for you may
choose instead to run a low rate of fire
weapon where you can control the recoil
a little better either way I've chosen
the assault rifle because it works best
at medium range and comes standard with
a good amount of enemy armor damage I
choose to use this build at medium to
close range
preferably medium so I don't end up
getting flanked the talents I'm learning
are what could be considered God role
PvE talents destructive predatory and
ferocious destructive enemy armor damage
is increased by 15% as I've mentioned
before this is a top tier PvE talent
predatory killing a target regenerates
35% health over 20 seconds this is the
best weapon talent for sustainability in
the game right now and ferocious damage
against elite and named enemies is
increased by 10% this will need to be
rolled into the third slot in order to
meet talent requirements the secondary
weapon is another light waiting for I'm
using the same talents as the primary
weapon except I changed up ferocious
forward determined this way after I've
used my signature skill I can swap over
to my secondary and charge it quickly
back up pro tip if you're using two
different weapons that look and feel the
same give them a different colored skin
here I've given my primary a [ __ ] and
my secondary orange it'll help you
quickly identify which weapon you're
using without having to go into your
loadout both weapons have one mod into
stability and the rest into increasing
critical hit damage another weapon
option is to swap out your secondary for
a shotgun because of the multiple
pellets being fired out you can very
quickly build up your striker stacks if
you'd like to try out a shotgun go for
something like the SAS G or showstopper
if you've managed to find one these have
a decent rate of fire and require you to
reload a magazine rather than each
individual shell stay away from double
barrel shotguns and please dear God
don't touch the Cassidy the Cassidy can
suck it hey there women
the skills I'm using is the tactical
scanner pulse and immunizes support
station tactical scanner for an increase
in critical hit damage and critical hit
charts and the immunize er as a healing
skill just placing the immunize er down
and letting it heal you slowly isn't
going to help you much especially since
your skill power is so low but the
master mod for support station discharge
gives the user and allies and range of
the station and immediate boost in
health placing down the support station
and then blowing it up will provide you
with 33% health regardless of skill
power level and why the immunize er over
other types the immunize er will help
with removing any status effects like
bleed or disorientation
the talents I'm running a critical save
strike back and on the move these will
all help with keeping you alive
the fourth talent is steady hands this
will help further reduce the recoil of
your weapon after entering cover you may
not need this particularly if you're on
PC in this case I changed it over for
something like precision
all gear mods are stamina damage to
elites stamina because in my situation I
wasn't getting quite enough toughness
from the gear pieces alone with the
performance mods I'm using pulse
critical hit chance this is to get a
little bit more out of my pulse and this
is also part of the reason why I'm not
running any critical hit chance weapon
mods
you don't have the survivability of a
nomad built and you can't just sit at
the back like a skill power build you
need to play this game as it was
originally intended as a cover shooter
you need to be all up in there but in a
smart way
this build is best utilized in a team
situation where your job is to burst
down the enemies and your damage output
more than fills this role while you're
getting comfortable with the new play
style you may find it easier just to
burst fire at it PCs to start with this
will help you control your firing
allowing you to keep increasing your
striker max used properly this build
will help your team quickly progress
through the most difficult content in
the game particularly when looking at
activities like resistance with the
bossed waves have a timer associated
with them another thing with this build
is that it'll help you get prepared for
the PvP aspect of the game sure the gear
olds will be a lot different and in PvP
you don't utilize the cover shooter
mechanics but the high DPS and low
toughness / survivability is very
similar now I'm not recommending you go
and take this build into the dark zone
and stuccoing Rogue on people but out of
the three beginner builds have shown
this is the closest we've gotten as far
as style of play goes play around with
this build and remember to adapt it to
your style of play next based on a lot
of the questions I've been receiving
I'll be throwing together a quick video
on weapon talents placing them in groups
of what situations they should be used
in like PvE and PvP and ranking them and
their effectiveness within these groups
from there I have a few ninja bite
builds planned that will open up a lot
more in the way of build options as I
said before keep the questions coming
even if they feel like there might be
noob questions you likely won't be alone
I'm doing my best to keep us a toxicity
free zone so don't be afraid to ask if I
can't answer the questions in the
comments or make sure to cover it in an
upcoming video I may not reply to all of
them but I read every comment and I
can't thank you guys enough for the
feedback so far I don't consider myself
a youtuber I just see myself as someone
passionate about gaming and if I can
assist others that are interested in the
same games as myself and help the game
grow of more than achieve my goal he'll
the main reason to monetize my videos is
to attempt to justify the amount of time
I spend on these videos to my wife and
playing games of course anyway thank you
again for watching this video hopefully
you found it useful and I'll see you in
the next one Cheers
[Music]